pn retour en france avec l'économie on
dit souvent que la recherche française
est en panne
et bien voici un contre exemple il
s'appelle françois bourdoncle il a 41
ans et il est tout simplement en train
de défier google le géant mondial des
moteurs de recherche sur internet
l'enjeu est donc immense sa petite
société exalead qui compte aujourd'hui
quarante salariés est en pleine
expansion
elle vient d'être choisie pour être au
coeur du projet de recherche quaero
lancé par jacques chirac
stéphane despinoy alexandra renard voici
deux champions du web
ils sont inconnus du grand public et
pourtant ils ont inventé un moteur de
recherche sur internet classer parmi les
trois meilleurs au monde fini désormais
la discrétion les voici installé face à
la madeleine
nous sommes passés en cinq ans du stade
de start up a aujourd'hui une société
internationale présente aux états unis
est présente également en italie où nous
avons maintenant une présence assez
importante d'ici ils comptent partir à
l'assaut du géant américain google la
machine est en marche plusieurs
milliards de pages internet ont déjà été
indexés en contenu exalead entend
bientôt faire jeu égal avec le site
américain bat pour les 4 milliards ça
suit son cours c'est presque fini il y
en a encore pour une semaine ou deux
calculs pour les milliards on attend la
livraison des machines la suite jusqu'à
présent ils ont vendu des moteurs de
recherche à des entreprises la nouvelle
étape c'est donc un site grand public de
recherche de documents un vrai défi à
relever puisque 80 % des internautes
français ont le réflexe google c'est un
peu le combat de david contre goliath
bien sûr mais j'ai connu
j'ai connu altavista à l'époque où
google n'existait encore pas apte à
vista était le roi du search à l'époque
et finalement vous savez c'est google
qui l'a emporté donc il ya toujours de
la place dans le monde de l'informatique
pour des nouveaux entrants n'a jamais
gagné la guerre voici le saint des
saints pour cet ex jeunes pousses qui se
rêve en géant de la toile
vu la production d'exalead vous avez
donc humain
milliards de pages la moitié le web
mondial certaines machines acquiert les
pages d'autres les fêtes les classes les
free et à la fin mai
qui vous servirez d'état quand vous
posez des questions moteur les deux
fondateurs ont encore un défi à relever
baptisé leur moteur de recherche grand
public trouver un nom facilement
mémorisable pour un internaute de paris
comme de cali forme voilà et la soeur